wir können uns menschen so bauen wie wir
wollen jedenfalls sind wir kurz davor
die als weggehen schere dafür und
superstar der biotechnologie heißt chris
backus neuen technologie kurz christa
die euphorie ist groß erbkrankheiten und
krebs könnten damit geheilt werden und
menschliche embryonen wurden mit
christopher bereits verändert und genau
das macht vielen angst euer dem
vorschlag über whatsapp hier die
aktuelle situation bei pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen und vielen
dank für den themenvorschlag hierzu
whatsapp kommt und dort team vorschläge
machen können das erfahrt ihr am ende
des videos
fangen wir mit den erfolgsmeldungen und
positiven seiten von küster klas dem
neuen allzweckwerkzeug der gentechnik an
kurz noch einmal zur erklärung mit
dieser methode lassen sich ausgewählte
gene einfügen ausschalten oder auch
umschreiben und zwar sehr einfach es
funktioniert ganz simpel wie eine schere
es im august 2017 kamen dann das
unglaubliche heraus wir menschen sind in
der lage gezielt in die evolution
einzugreifen kaputte gehen raus aus dem
körper gesunde gene rein und schon ist
die erbkrankheit besiegt oder viel
schlimmer wir bauen uns den super
menschen mit einer einfachen und
effektiven technik unvorstellbar
doch genau das ist jetzt einem us
wissenschaftsteam an menschlichen
embryonen gelungen das forschungsteam
aus portland befruchtete in ihrem
versuch gesunde eizellen mit spermien
eines spenders der an einer
herzmuskelschwäche litt sie spritzten
nicht nur die spermien sondern eben auch
entsprechende kaspar proteine in die
eizelle diese sollten den kaputten
ausschnitt der die erbkrankheit auslöst
ausschneiden und durch einen gesunden
abschnitt ersetzen und tatsächlich in 42
von 58 millionen war der gen defekt
behoben war
doch nicht zu 100 prozent denn dieser
versuch hat genau wie vergleichbare
experimente deutliche schwächen und die
sind nicht ohne konkret war bei dem
experiment etwas seltsames passiert
nicht der künstliche dna schnipsel der
kürzere proteine wo die in die embryos
eingebaut sondern der gesunde schnitzel
aus der natürlichen eizelle der
eigentlich als kopiervorlage zur
reparatur diete zugespitzt formuliert
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wissen nicht was sie da
getan haben
ähnliche versuche
mussten frühzeitig abgebrochen werden es
gab viel zu viele ungeplanten
genveränderung die ungeahnte
konsequenzen mit sich bringen könnten
den tod der embryos fehlbildung krebs
oder andere erkrankungen das ist das
riesige problem von christa zu viel geht
im wahrsten sinne des wortes daneben zu
viel wird auch an anderen stellen des
erbgutes verändert und das zum teil
ziemlich unkontrolliert trotzdem zeigt
der versuch des us forschungsteams das
gentechnisch modifizierte kinder keine
zukunftsmusik mehr sind sondern
wahrscheinlich nur noch eine frage der
zeit
weitere große hoffnungen setzt das
forschungsteam in die behandlung anderer
bislang unheilbare krankheiten um
beispielsweise mit hilfe einer
gentherapie überzählige chromosomen
gezielt zu entfernen und das ist
wirklich was eigentlich super positives
in einem japanischen experiment wurde
jetzt gezeigt dass das kein werkzeug
tatsächlich auch anders kann
statt die gewohnte feinarbeit gab es ein
regelrechtes gemetzel und ja es grenzt
schon an eine sensation denn dem
forschungsteam ist es gelungen ein
komplettes chromosom im wahrsten sinne
des wortes zu pulverisiert dafür
züchteten sie im labor zellen eines
menschen mit trisomie 21 auch das down
syndrom genannt
ihr habt es vielleicht mal im
biologieunterricht mitbekommen bei
dieser erkrankung liegt das chromosom 21
drei statt zwei mal vor bislang gibt es
keine möglichkeit die erkrankung noch im
mutterleib zu behandeln das sagt doch
das experiment aus japan macht
tatsächlich hoffnung dass dies demnächst
möglich sein könnte vielleicht sogar
während der schwangerschaft auch andere
krankheiten wie beispielsweise das
kleinfelder syndrom bei dem ein
zusätzliches x-chromosom vorliegt oder
das sogenannte xy incident syndrom
könnten so behandelt werden dieses
ergebnis ist tatsächlich ein hammer und
vielleicht sogar der anfang eines neuen
zeitalters tor realistisch gesehen ist
diese methodik noch nicht wirklich
bereit für die praxis denn es gibt viel
zu viele schnitte an stellen die so ganz
und gar nicht gewollt sind nicht
vorstellbar was passieren würde wenn in
einem lebenden organismus die falschen
chromosomen zerstört würden zudem ist
die effizienz mit einer erfolgsquote von
40 prozent bisher zu gering ein weiterer
forschungsbereich in dem die christa
klaß technologie eine große rolle spielt
ist die organtransplantation auch über
dieses forschungsergebnis hatten
bei klicks um science-fiction berichtet
einem internationalen forschungsteam war
es im letzten sommer gelungen eine hürde
für die transplantation von schweine
organen in menschen zu eliminieren der
mensch wird mit solchen organ zur
chimäre mischwesen aus zwei organismen
ein großer erfolg denn forschungsteams
weltweit forschen daran dass auch
tierorganen menschen helfen könnten die
nur noch durch eine organspende die
chance haben weiter zu leben auch
schweine kämen als organspender für uns
menschen in betracht sie sind ja und
sehr sehr ähnlich doch ende der 90er
jahre wurden viren im genom der schweine
identifiziert die wohl gefährlich für
den menschen sein könnten
diese portionen endogenen retroviren
kurzpass so heißen diese viren könnten
dort immundefekte und krebs verursachen
einem internationalen wissenschafts team
ist nun das gelungen woran viele andere
vor ihnen gescheitert waren natürlich
mit der chris methode sie hatten rund 30
ferkel erschaffen die frei von diesen
retroviren waren jetzt plant das
forschungsteam den per freien
schweinestall weiterzuentwickeln und
damit dann sicher und wirksam dass
schweine herz in einen menschen zu
verpflanzen der fachbegriff dafür
xenotransplantation noch gibt es
zahlreiche schwierigkeiten zu überwinden
bislang konnten primaten nicht lange
überleben denen gentechniker schweine
organe eingesetzt hatten
alle der sehr wenigen versuche
schweineherzen den menschen zu
transportieren sind ausnahmslos
gescheitert denn das menschliche
immunsystem bekämpft fremdes gewebe
selbst das von anderen menschen
das studienergebnis klingt sicher erst
einmal spannend doch viele fragen
bleiben noch hoffen abzuwarten bleibt
beispielsweise wie lange die gezüchteten
ferkel ohne die retroviren im genom
überleben werden bis jetzt weiß man
nämlich noch nicht sicher ob sie diese
zu überleben brauchen aber was ist wenn
sie weiterleben und dann noch einen weg
gefunden wird die schweineherzen
gentechnisch zu verändern zu diesen
ganzen fragen kommt ein weiterer aspekt
hinzu
der moralische sind schweine als
ersatzteillager für menschen vertretbar
und wo führt uns das alle sind viele
viele fragen und noch viel zu wenige
antworten denn das problem ist dass die
meisten menschen außerhalb der
wissenschaftswelt zu wenig über diese
technik wissen um ihr potenzial ihre
chancen und vor allem auch ihre risiken
abzuwägen
der ethikrat plan zwar eine
stellungnahme zu den eingriffen mit der
gen scheren in die keimbahn doch muss es
vielmehr den
zu diesem thema ähnlich wie zum
klimawandel oder der atomenergie geben
wir müssen dringend reflektieren welches
risiko sie eingehen wollen und dabei
auch an die nachfolgenden generationen
denken und hier ist die politik gefragt
denn im medizinischen bereich herrscht
bezüglich der gen schere eine art
goldgräberstimmung die abheben lässt
zudem fließen milliarden vom forschungs-
und investitionsgelder nein die die
euphorie noch größer werden lassen
allerhöchste zeit also für die gründung
einer offiziellen institutionen die das
ganze überwacht und regulieren kann und
jetzt der aber keine werbung mehr auf
klicks wir haben ja schon angefangen
immer mehr videos sind werbefrei
dank eurer hilfe immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder
gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
vor einem video habt werdet also
mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken und er bekommt noch
exklusiv wir extra videos live streams
und noch ein paar weitere privilegien
für einen kleinen beitrag wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp da könnt ihr auch
themenvorschläge machen wie diesen hier
und ihr bekommt den link zum aktuellen
video deutlich vor allen andern von mir
persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken werden gehen
soldaten jetzt realität bis dann bleibt
dran